und dann auch noch den youtube namen des
anderen users sozusagen in den
kommentaren sperren lässt das finde ich
schon sehr blöd und da fühle ich mich
auch ein bisschen fühle mich einfach
verarscht so hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video erneut ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut mir jetzt eigentlich auch ziemlich
gut
bis auf eine sache die jetzt so halt
mein youtube betrifft die mich ein
bisschen nachdenklich macht und ja worum
ich mir halt ein bisschen sorgen mache
weshalb ich jetzt auf dieses video
machte zuvor würde ich sehr gerne noch
sagen ich denke das wissen ja die
meisten von euch auch ich bin eine
person ich habe also ich bin der letzte
der irgendwie streit anfangen möchte
oder irgendwelche negativen negativen
vibes verbreiten möchte es geht einfach
nur darum dass ich mir halt so ein
bisschen sorgen mache und mich das
natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr
verstehe dieses video aber bitte auf
keinen fall falsch also es soll jetzt
hier nicht irgendwie so ein brief
angezettelt werden
es geht einfach nur um eine erklärung
also ich würde es einfach mal unter dem
begriff erklärt video abstempeln und
zwar hab dieses jahr wahrscheinlich am
titel schon gelesen es geht heute um die
liebe rebecca ring
ich glaube ich eine persönlichkeit in
youtube deutschland um die man
mittlerweile eigentlich so nur noch
schwierig herumkommt den namen haben
wahrscheinlich alle von euch schon mal
gewagt oder die meisten zumindest auch
ich so das ding ist nämlich habe jetzt
in den letzten tagen sehr oft auf
instagram nachricht bekommen oder dass
auch unter meinen eigenen youtube videos
gelesen alex mir tut das vielleicht dass
deine videos manchmal einfach kopiert
werden das habe ich jetzt in den letzten
tagen ein paar mal gelesen und da dachte
ich so ja danke dass ihr das leid tut
was genau meinst du denn jetzt so also
so habe ich zumindest zunächst möchte
ich mich also ein bisschen zurück
erinnern und zwar an diese zeit wo ich
so auf zeugnisse reagiert habe da habe
ich halt irgendwann mal damit angefangen
und das war so ein kleiner hype in
deutschland dann haben immer mehr leute
auf diese zeugnisse sein geld könnt ihr
euch ja wahrscheinlich noch daran
erinnern und das war für mich auch schon
so wo ich gesagt habe bin ich gar nicht
mal schlecht dass so viele das mache ich
meine
ja auch irgendwie was cooles so dass du
mal so einen kleinen trend gesetzt dass
das hat mich sehr gefreut und man muss
ja noch dazu sagen sehr viele leute
haben sogar gesagt dass sie das bei mir
gesehen haben das war jetzt einfach mal
so ein beispiel aus der vergangenheit
ich habe jetzt vor allem im jahr 2019
auch so ein bisschen meinen denn
geändert habe viele essens videos
gemacht und so und ich habe das jetzt
hier mal aufgerufen
vor zwei wochen ich bin es euch hier
gern mal ein essen bei der schlecht ist
eine eisdiele im schlimmsten stadtteil
meiner stadt also so heißt das video das
wiederholt mir komischerweise direkt
angezeigt obwohl ich sie nicht mehr
abonniert habe vermutlich aus dem grund
weil ich vor 12 monaten keine ahnung
selber so ein video gemacht habe ich
esse in der schlechtesten eisdiele meyer
stadt vielleicht habe das ja einige von
euch gesehen das video auch ich mir
angeschaut und dachte so ab vielleicht
ist sie ja so nett und sagt dass sie das
bei mir gesehen hat weil das ist so der
erste gedanke den man als youtuber hat
hat hier nicht und ich darf mir so okay
kein problem ich mein wenn man das cool
fand so ich bin da gar nicht so dass ich
dass ich dann direkt sage oder dann es
gibt auch youtuber die schreiben dann so
ein kommentar so ironisch cooles video
oder so so bin ich gar nicht habe ich
mir gedacht stehst du darüber nur man
muss halt ganz klar sagen dieses video
hat über einer halben million und jus
mehr als dreifach soviel wie mein video
wo ich in der eisdiele ist oder sogar
vierfach keine ahnung und natürlich
verbinden die meisten das dann damit
dass ich das bei ihr abgeschaut habe
obwohl das ja gar nicht so ist aber wie
gesagt das fand ich doch gar nicht so
schlimm habe ich ja auch irgendwie
wieder vergessen vielleicht sollte man
dazu mal kurz die story hinter dem
format erzählen also ich habe vor abbau
über einem halben jahr damit mal
angefangen da war ich im schlechtesten
burger restaurant in meiner stadt essen
kann ich euch hier sehr gerne einbinden
um ehrlich zu sein habe ich dann
irgendwann aber wieder aufgehört wird im
format weil ich auch gar nicht so auf
die idee gekommen
du kannst es ja eigentlich noch in
anderen restaurants machen ist ein
freund von mir mich darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat und dann hab ich das halt
einfach weiter durchgezogen und es kam
auch war in drei wochen bestimmt 56
videos zu dem thema
unter anderem hat auch der schlechteste
dönerladen die schlechteste pizzeria und
bei der rebecca kam halt auch vor
einigen tagen dieses video also es war
dass es im schlimmsten
was sich immer noch gar nicht schlimm
finde um ehrlich zu sein ja ich meine
bei ihr ist es noch mal vielleicht in
einer anderen stadt wohnt er vermutlich
nehmen können keine ahnung was ich ein
bisschen schade finde ich habe mir beide
videos so relativ lang angeguckt und die
sind halt eigentlich genau so aufgebaut
wie mainz ich meine vom tempo her und
auch im inhalt erst werden irgendwelche
rezensionen vorgelesen dann wird zum
laden gefahren dann gibt es noch ein
paar zieht so habe ich das auch gemacht
von sicherlich ist das auch ein
logischer auch keine frage aber trotzdem
stellt euch mal vor ihr wählt so in
dieser situation ihr macht so ganz viele
videos zu dem thema das ist so euer ding
und dann kommt jemand der noch eine viel
größere reichweite hat und mach das
einfach halt genauso nach und sagt ja
nicht mal dass es von euch ist und die
meisten leute verbinden dass dann
automatisch ich will mit dir sondern
halt mit wem anderes und da kann sich ja
dann eigentlich jeder logisch vorstellen
dass sich das blöd anfühlt oder dann
nimmt man sich halt schade ich bin mir
eigentlich ziemlich sicher dass sie das
video sehen wird weiland chance ja
manchmal bei mir vorbei und kann auch
sehr gut sein dass in zukunft noch
weitere solche restaurant test videos
von dir kommen so ist ja kein problem
kannst du sehr gerne machen wie gesagt
ich fand es nur schade dass man das halt
dann so macht für mich wäre das jetzt
aber auch noch gar kein grund gewesen
dieses videos machen nur weil sie es
halt im schlechtesten dönerladen und in
der schlechtesten eisdiele war die
videos relativ gleich aufgebaut hat wie
ich und nicht gesagt hat das ist bei mir
gesehen hat so ok alles cool dann hab
ich vor ungefähr zwei wochen
das video hochgeladen die person vor mir
entscheidet was ich esse inspiriert vom
englischen youtube direct das habe ich
im video auch gesagt im video habe ich
euch gefragt ob ich dass ich auch mal
irgend welchen läden machen soll wie zum
beispiel bei gucci apple oder sonstwas
und dann wurden mir irgendwann wieder
ein video von rebecca vorschlag und in
dem video das wir von ihm vorgeschlagen
wurde geht es darum die person vor mir
entscheidet was ich erste für 24 stunden
was ja vielleicht sogar gar nicht mal
von mir geklaut wurde sondern von dem
derrick aus amerika auch wenn die
vermutung natürlich nahe liegt dass es
dann bei mir gesehen wurde
keine ahnung aber ich will jetzt auch
nichts unterstellen nun weiß ich mich
dann gefragt habe gehe ich gestern auf
youtube wird mit dem video vorgeschlagen
ich hatte halt nächste woche vor weitere
patz davon zu drehen habe ich auch im
video schon angekündigt dass ich das
machen werde
doch sehr gerne ideen für keine ahnung
macht es doch mal im gucci store oder so
kann man ja auch video von rebecca nur
das kaufen wie die person vor mir im
apple store in götzis denke da sollte
jeder nachvollziehen können dass es
einen natürlich dann ein bisschen sauer
macht einfach weil man ja schon einfach
im video gesagt hat ja das kommt dann so
als nächstes und dann einfach irgendein
anderer das macht der haupt
ausschlaggebende grund warum ich mich
dann aber jetzt die hingesetzt habe und
das video aufnehmen wo ich das versuche
aufzuklären damit jetzt nicht irgendwie
alles was bei mir hochgeladen wird
plötzlich auch bei ihr hochgeladen wird
und jeder denkt ich habe es geklaut
einfach weil meine reichweite nur halb
so groß ist und das ist finde ich auch
schon sehr drei ich hab das gestern mal
ausprobiert einfach weil ich mir auch so
die kommentare durchgelesen habe und
normalerweise steht immer dann grund
hajo das habe ich schon mal bei alex wie
gesehen oder so das ist ganz normal bei
der rebecca taucht allerdings nie
irgendwo mein name auf als ich habe
bestimmt 100 kommentare gelesen und das
hat mich so ein bisschen stutzig gemacht
dann habe ich einfach mal probiert warte
immer also das finde ich jetzt zwar
recht heftig aber hat sie wirklich
meinen youtube namen also oder das wort
alex wie auf diese blacklist für
kommentare gesetzt das heißt jeder der
alex wie in die kommentare schreibt wird
automatisch oder dieser kommentar wird
niemand angezeigt landet dann direkt im
spamordner was weiß ich das habe ich mal
mit meinem zweit account getestet ich
kann es euch gerne zeigen wir sind jetzt
bei dem video sf schlimmsten döner pizza
pommes in meiner stadt so ich bin auf
meinem dritt account oder so angemeldet
und jetzt machen wir mal folgendes ich
kommentiere mal kurz cool sagt selbst
wenn dieser ausdruck cool jetzt auf
dieser liste sein würde mit den
gesperrten wörtern könnte ich meinen
kommentar hier trotzdem sehen weil ich
denn mit diesem account verfasst habe
und dann kann das halt nur ich sind wir
wechseln jetzt mal kurz auf meinen
hauptkanal ja also ist jetzt ein anderer
kanal ein anderer account sind beim
gleichen video neueste zuerst und haben
hier den kommentar cool jetzt habe ich
mich wieder um gelobt leute was geht
jetzt kann ich den kommentar ja
eigentlich wieder löschen hier hat
gesehen das ist halt ganz normal
zugänglich und jetzt kommentiere ich
einfach mal alex wie kommentieren das
habe ich ja gestern auch ausprobiert
jetzt laufe ich mich wieder um so
kommentare laden beim neueste zuerst
komisch meter gar nicht angezeigt und
das finde ich um ehrlich zu sein schon
wirklich ein bisschen traurig und blöd
und ich glaube das können sollte auch
jeder von euch verstehen können deswegen
habe ich kurz dieses video hier gemacht
wie gesagt nehmt das bitte nicht als
streit oder sonst was auch das gibt mir
lediglich eigentlich um mich dass ich in
zukunft weiterhin in ruhe meine videos
und meine ideen umsetzen kann und keine
angst haben muss dass mir irgendwie
vorgeworfen wird ich hatte das von der
nach gemacht was ich zum schluss aber
auch noch sagen möchte
da ich sicherlich auch nicht das
paradebeispiel für 100% eigenen ideen
bin als ich habe mich auch schon sehr
oft aus amerika oder so inspirieren
lassen dann sollte man aber auch so fair
sein und sagen ja das ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt meine idee ich hab es da
gesehen wobei das halt dann auch
komplett andere sprachen und andere
zielgruppen sind wenn man dann aber aus
deutschland die sachen kopiert und dann
noch den youtube namen des anderen user
ist sozusagen in den kommentaren sperren
lässt das finde ich schon sehr blöd und
da fühle ich mich auch ein bisschen über
fühle mich einfach verarscht so das
video geht jetzt sicherlich auch schon
über zehn minuten ich werde keine
werbung schalten oder sonst was es geht
mir einfach nur um diese eine sache dass
jetzt einmal aufgedeckt und erklärt zu
haben damit ich jetzt weiterhin solche
kommentare nicht mehr lesen muss jetzt
weiß jeder bescheid das war zu mir
haut rein